what's up everyone Mary here with a  GameSpot news update it looks like a lot  of kiddies got Xbox ones under their  tree because Xbox one officially outsold  ps4 for December Microsoft revealed in a  press statement that they are number one  in console sales in the US for the  second consecutive month in a row in  addition to having the number one  consoles Microsoft revealed that they  were also ahead on the software front  Xbox one sold more games throughout  November in December in the US than any  other current generation platform the  success of the Xbox one could at least  be partly attributed to the price drop  which brought bundles from the system  down to about 350 bucks undercutting the  ps4  by 50 the price will back up to $400 in  early January but is returning to the  lower price tomorrow well congrats to  the Microsoft we've got more NPD news  including the top 10 games of 2014 at  GameSpot calm slash news